the media the corporate press the
mainstream media just lies to us about
everything so when when it's their guys
burning down the cities and destroying
best buys and targets and pep boys and
whatever else those are the good guys
and we should be tolerant of it but when
it's peaceful people you know protesting
for freedom they're bad guys they're
right-wing maniacs alt-right etc etc
here's mr potato head himself brian
stelter over on c
n
n
i was just googling that old quote from
john stewart mill he talked about your
rights and where my nose begins so like
your freedom sometimes infringes on
others freedom and i think donal what
you've seen in in in canada is others
are fearful of these protesters who are
arguing for freedom right because of
some of the fringe rhetoric can we play
the daily show clip for a second this
was you appearing on the daily show and
then trevor noah had a reaction
and because you're not vaccinated have
you
is there businesses there stuff you
can't do in canada now
yeah like i'm like i'm like well
basically if you want to compare canada
uh to anything it's like uh hitler's
germany
and we're like the jews eh
you see this is why we shouldn't be
banning books
[Laughter]
i can't say it better than trevor noah
yeah look and i mean there is that
that's a really big part of what we're
seeing there and and the re that just
doesn't come from anywhere right because
that that that that terrible historical
inaccurate comparison uh we've heard
members of congress here repeated but
it's actually i think a lot of it is
based in there's been so much
demonization of public health officials
in this country and elsewhere right um
that a lot of these people believe that
public health officials are there to
harm and hurt them not to help them
right it's the bigger picture here is
online radicalization
of lots of different kinds turns into
offline action and whether there end up
being convoys in the us or not we're
already seeing the impacts of that in
canada i feel like that's your beat
dhoni is it's the online radicalization
but then you see what happens in real in
in real life
i i just said to my guys as we were
playing this it's truly incredible
watching these people flip the story and
how they reverse everything they say
about one thing when it's their guys
doing it versus how
they say it when it's the other guys
doing it first off i just want to say
something very very clearly here
i lost family members on both sides of
the holocaust okay i grew up around
holocaust survivors i am well versed in
what the holocaust was and what the
demonization of people is
um although
the guy who was interviewed there and by
the way great cherry picking on that
daily show and then they they cherry
pick that on the daily show
and then of course they throw that to
cnn because they're all in on it
together i believe they're both owned by
viacom it's just one big circle jerk in
essence um
just for regardless of what the guy said
whether whether you think he said it in
a butchered way or or he shouldn't say
it or something like that
the way something like the holocaust
starts is you otherwise people right you
keep otherizing otherizing them you say
oh you can't be part of the economy you
can't own a store you can't do this
we're going to demonize you you're
diseased
so it is not a giant leap okay it really
is not and i don't care how much hate i
get for this it is not a giant leap
after two years of demonizing certain
people who wanted choice medical choice
and choice used to be thought of as a
good thing
to compare them to the jews before the
holocaust it's not a perfectly
symmetrical
situation right there aren't gas
chambers in canada yet
okay so it's not perfect but it is not
deeply wrong and the the message behind
what he said
the message behind what he said was
basically right so stelter laughs at it
and and
trevor noah who has a series of highly
we covered it last week highly offensive
jokes if you get offended by jokes
towards jews who's now trying to destroy
joe rogan uh you know he this is why you
know we shouldn't burn books okay fine
but this is what they do this is what
they do this is brian stelter who as
the cities in america burned he excused
it this is what they did on cnn they
constantly excuse this don't worry guys
when when blm is burning cities when
antifa is burning cities when cities are
burning because there's an orange man in
charge or something like that then it's
all good it's all good i want to be
clear in how i characterize this this is
a mostly a protest uh it is not uh it is
not generally speaking unruly that ain't
a riot what we're seeing right now in
minneapolis is they are strictly
principled anti-fascists and they've
taken a principle stand to stand against
white supremacists and white
nationalists wherever they may show up i
argue to you tonight all punches
are not equal
morally it says it right in the name
antifa anti-fascism which is what they
were there
fighting listen there's you know no
organization is perfect there was some
violence any reasonable person would say
we shouldn't be destroying other
people's property but these are not
reasonable times but thank goodness for
the looters man and please show me where
it says that protests are supposed to be
polite and peaceful i don't care that
much about statues
respectfully shouldn't that be done by a
commission or the city council not a mob
in the middle of the night throwing it
into the harlem we'll do what they do
you're seeing behind me is one of
multiple locations that have been
burning in kenosha wisconsin do not get
it twisted and think that oh this is
some something that has not never
happened before and then this is so
terrible and where are we in these
savages and all of that this is how this
country was started people get mad and
people get sick of it people are risking
covid
to explain to this country that we're
fed up most of the major movements in
american history have started at the
grassroots level and at some point have
turned into direct conflict with
american government so
remember your history before you judge
your presence sluggishness is
thuggishness wherever it comes from
politically and we should be the first
to call it out i disagree
dare i quote chris cuomo
but remember your history
remember that history that i just showed
you remember that those people excuse
violence those people actually instigate
violence